well hey there thankk you for being here
and an especially warm welcome if this
is your first time with us Adventist or
otherwise so tonight we're going to be
talking about the doctrine of
justification more specifically
justification by faith this is a
doctrine that was Central to the
Protestant Reformation as Professor Mark
Thompson notes in the book The Doctrine
on which the church stands or Falls
where he writes quote the Deep ground of
the doctrine of justification only by
faith is the person character and
purpose of the Triune God and its focus
is the death of Jesus Christ for sinners
in the body of Christian teaching this
Doctrine has a special place guarding
and securing the priority of grace and
the entire sufficiency of the atonement
affected by Christ in shorthand
justification is only by faith because
salvation is only by Christ and
salvation only by Christ is the
outworking of God's Eternal gracious
purpose anchored in the immeasurable
depth of his Triune life this is why
Martin Luther spoke of this Doctrine as
the article by which the church stands
or Falls if the Christian confession
fails at this point it compromises our
utter dependence on Christ and the sheer
gratuiti of Grace and as a result the
Christian Life corporately as well as
individually begins to unravel close
quote which means that from a Protestant
perspective this is an area of
significance and severity and the
Adventist Church claims to affirm
justification by faith as we see in the
exposition of their 28 fundamental
beliefs where they write quote through
justification by faith in Christ his
righteousness is imputed to us we are
right with God because of Christ Our
substitute God Paul said made him who
knew no sin to be sin for us that we
might become the righteousness of God in
him 1 Corinthians 5:21 as repentant
Sinners we experience full and complete
pardon we are reconciled to God close
quote sounds pretty good right well
tonight we're going to be examining this
further and see if this is another case
of borrowing terminology while meaning
something entirely different and I've
got the perfect guest to help us out
Heraldo kamacho is a sinner justified by
the life death and resurrection of Jesus
Christ Our Lord born a little over 75
years ago in Colombia his journey has
taken him from infancy in an SDA
pastor's home to becoming an Adventist
Minister missionary theology professor
and Conference secretary until the holy
spirit intervened in his life with the
gospel of God's justifying Grace which
he confesses to have received by faith
alone in the merits of Christ currently
Heraldo has a YouTube Ministry reaching
several thousands of Spanish-speaking
sdas and former sdas he lives in Florida
with his wife Mercedes and their
14-year-old son Orlando he praises the
Lord Jesus Christ for his NeverEnding
mercies and he serves as a lay minister
in Our Savior Lutheran Church in
Plantation Florida so you guys hear me
use the phrase scaling the language
barrier a lot I constantly highlight
that definitions matter so that's what
we're going to be doing tonight and
pinpoint where exactly the rub is
between what the SDA church is claiming
when they use the phrase justification
by faith over and against the Apostle
Paul specifically in the book of
Galatians let's get into
it all right brother thank you for
sharing some of your time with us I'm
really looking forward to the discussion
how are you today I am well miles thank
you for inviting me once again to your
channel which I uh really appreciate
it's very Dynamic and
uh all your guests are great and right
on well thank you um people loved the
last time that you were on it was in a
bit of a different format we were kind
of telling your story today we're going
to talk about justification and I'm
really looking forward to it to kick
things off though many in the audience
may not know that you have translated
Martin Luther's commentary on the book
of Galatians it is available through
1517 publishing it is a beautifully
printed book but to kick us off what
prompted your desire to translate
Luther's commentary on the book of
Galatians because it is a massive
commentary well it I didn't start out
saying I'm going to translate Luther's
commentary
but um after I left the SE theist
church I wanted to answer many lingering
questions on my mind you know adventism
and its doctrines get so it's like worms
they get all over your brain and leave
tracks and uh a text here will lead down
this Foxhole to that one thing so I
wanted to
um answer for myself many of those
things so I began to study and frankly
miles I don't know at which point I
found Luther's
commentary because even though I took
the Epistle of Galatians exegetical
course in the
Seminary it wasn't on the reading
list there were many other books on
their reading list but it wasn't there
in fact when my first edition of
Luther's commentary came out in Spanish
because it was translated first into
Spanish I called which would make an
interesting call uh on a live um setting
to call a seminary live and ask how many
copies they have of Luther's commentary
on
Galatians when I called which is over 10
years ago um they put me on
hold um it took a while for them to get
back and they said we have one
copy and I said great I would like to
borrow it and they said you can't oh I
said it must be on
reserve and uh the U lady on the other
side said no it's on a special type of
Reserve serve where only a selected list
that's already um made uh can um can
borrow the the book and they have to
read it right here in a special room
it's not allowed to be taken
out and so I said how do I get on that
special list I am a graduate and she
said no you have to be recommended by
the committee chair to be on the speci
and a lot of things click together for
me it's like
okay um they don't want this commentary
to be read and of course if it was
studied and read the uh seven the
Adventist Church would come apart at the
seams that's how it is so um portions or
the the commentary came to me someone
sent me a a link to it this was way
before Facebook it was around the year
2000 and the first thing I did was to
order a copy of Luther's commentary and
there were several English copies
available um there was Watson's copy of
54 uh and um very good but it retained
the quite a bit of the Victorian English
but he had done an important thing he
had retained or found the parts that
were
excised by the uh English the first
English translators who did not want to
offend zwingley and his followers so
they cut out a um a great deal of his um
his more explicit statements on
justification and uh what Watson did is
that he rescued those parts so I am just
amazed at the whole story behind this
commentary which is told very well by
Watson uh and then I began to read it
and when Facebook came out a lot of
people former students of mine in um
Lima because I had been a advertis
theology Professor um of systematic
theology in uh in Lima in the Advent
Seminary there began um saying to me
that I was a traitor that why had I left
adven his doctrine that I was so
disloyal and didn't I know that the law
was still binding and why had I left the
Sabbath and uh they began to quote me on
things I had said about the legitimacy
of Ellen
White I had been a big promoter of I was
hr's
secretary and they remembered how I had
defended um that book and that uh all of
the stuff in there was true and of
course by I had not read or understood
Arthur White's um uh double speak to say
the least about the the story of I was
canri secretary so I began to post in
Spanish translating from Watson's uh
version uh to Spanish um clips from uh
from
Luther and what I found was outstanding
it was like I couldn't believe it um so
I just want to read some of those clips
that I began to to post on on Facebook
when Facebook finally came out I yeah
let's go to it you said that you could
post that page up yeah here we
are uh it's it was the doctrine of
justification because I had been
attracted by the doctrine of
justification um I had followed from
afar um some of um brimm's preaching and
writings when he converted to
justification but and he had quoted
Luther but now I found Luther for myself
and it was
amazing uh these are some of the quotes
with all
confidence we can say that we are
Justified not by our own works but
through relief provided outside of us
that relief is none other than God's
only son he has redeemed us from sin
death and the devil and has given to us
the gift of eternal life and I couldn't
believe what I was reading and he says I
don't publish my thoughts in this
epistle hoping to get a favorable review
from
unbelievers instead these thoughts will
rattle them and their
God uh if one haris he dies not much
later another one Springs up for the
devil neither slumbers nor sleeps I
attest to have been pestered by over 20
sects some of which have already
perished others like parts of a
dismembered insect are still twitching
and I could not help but think of seven
the
adventism uh this is our glory to be
found firm and fighting on behalf of the
seed of the woman against the seed of
the serpent let it bite our heal all at
once once on our part we will not cease
to crush its head through Christ the
first one to crush it may he be blessed
forever and ever
amen um this is our anchor our
foundation the gospel does not command
us to be looking at our service our
Perfection but to God who promises and
to Christ the
mediator um I could just keep on going
but
you know just go a few more in the
gospel we hear God say look I gave my
son over to sin and death by his blood
he redeemed you from sin and eternal
death then I cannot doubt unless I were
to deny God altogether this is the
reason for the certainty of our Doctrine
because it takes us out and away from
ourselves Paul always has Christ on his
lips and cannot forget him for he
anticipated that Christ and his gospel
would be most ignored in the world even
among professed Christians so I am
reading
Luther and being used to reading Ellen
White and all the Adventist uh Defenders
of uh of her faith because it's really
it's really her faith uh or
what James White um created her faith to
be
um I am reading and expecting the other
shoe to
fall and the other shoe to fall in all
other EG white writings and any
Adventist author you
mention is the
but however allbe it
and then is a very Cy camouflaged turn
sometimes not so camouflaged turn into
the obedience to the law to the Ten
Commandments and eventually they all
land on the Sabbath and so on so as I am
reading Luther I already knew that he
was not a Sabbath keeper and that's
another story but
um um I am expecting Luther to go down
the same um
hole but I keep Turning Page after page
and it's nothing but Grace forgiveness
of sins justification through Christ
Alone through faith alone and this book
all of a sudden gets um wrapped
around uh my my conscience and begins
spraying it it goes down all these
rabbit holes uh left over from adventism
those um um
tracks um left by what do they call that
it's something like
neuroplasticity where uh stuff that you
read or do uh finds and and leaves
several tracks in your brain and uh Here
Comes Luther and gets into all these old
tracks creating new tracks of um of um
gospel and mercy and justification so
much so that uh my previous students who
have been criticizing me begin to write
to me so Luther is your new
prophet and I say I'd rather have Luther
than Ellen White any day there is more
truth in one one page of Luther than in
all of Ellen White's writings and
Visions put together so in answer to
your
question um that's how my interest in
Luther got uh uh stimulated got started
uh but I had no intention of translating
the book because as you mentioned it is
massive it's over 500 pages and uh I
didn't see myself qualif ified to do
that I had not gone to school of course
in a Lutheran School uh I knew that um
it these had been uh this had been
written in Latin to begin with and then
as I delved a little further I realized
that these were lectures given by Luther
from um July
3r through December
12th um 1531 it was a total of 41
lectures and he lectured mainly Tuesdays
um two uh Tuesdays Thursdays and
Saturday nights and it was uh yes after
Sundown and uh you can only see Luther
in that Hall with um oil lamps hanging
from the wall and there's the smoke uh
going through the room and uh however
uncomfortable that is Luther would
lecture for up to two hours every night
on the epistle to the Galatians now this
is
1531 the room is full of seminarians
most of them were had been Catholic
priests who had now converted to the
gospel and there were a few lay people
who had requested to be part of the
class so I began to picture myself as
coming through the back door and finding
a bench and sitting down and uh since I
was um so enthralled by this I imagined
Luther up in front dictating his class
and I was participating in the class
there were three students of Luther um
gor rorer was the main one who invented
a Shand of their own a Latin shorthand
and they took notes and uh
uh together they would meet every now
and then and compare notes and write one
draft and then give it to Luther for his
um final reading and editing which uh
Luther did but left it mainly as it
was these lectures are as close a
transcript as um we could possibly get
to an audio recording of uh Luther in
the classroom
because neither the U Luther's students
nor Luther himself uh rewrote or edited
the lectures as an academic document it
was much later that when um other
editors um took it um particularly when
the English collected uh uh works of
Luther was edited and
translated by yis pelican in I think it
was 1961 that that whole series was
published um that u i uh saw for the
first time what they had done to Luther
it reads like an academic uh uh
document um
so that was so enthralling to be sitting
there in that classroom because that was
pretty much my experience
and uh I want to quote from a um a
review written by Dr Robert
corobb professor of systematic theology
Emeritus Concordia Seminary St Louis and
this is recently after the book was
published in English now for those who
know something about Lutheran and
Lutheran
um
studies Dr coob is the
preeminent historian of
Luther um he is now up in years but he
still holds command of Luther's life
with dates and uh documents and it is
fascinating to read things written by do
coob so 1517 wanted a good editorial
review in
Amazon and this is uh Amazon I'm reading
directly from the page where um my um my
translation is found see there it is
lecture notes transcribed by students
and presented in today's English and it
was my purpose to translate from the
Latin as precisely as possible um and
the same register that Luther had used I
didn't want to change the register into
an academic uh piece of
literature um I wanted to keep the Latin
and I I uh taught myself Latin in order
to translate this and found out that the
Latin was a vernacular Latin Luther is
very dynamic dynamic in his use of the
Latin very expressive one can catch his
humor his
sarcasm uh throughout the entire
document he was an amazing
teacher and I would I you know I could
almost see him because that's how it
reads in some places as if he would get
into a student's face and ask and say
the questions that he does so it's
amazing now this is what Dr coob says
who is the preeminent Lutheran
historians he says the translators
experience as a court translator and
transcriber I was only a court
translator and his training as a
theologian combined to enable him to
give readers a sense of the liveliness
of Martin Luther's lecture Style by
turning to student notes from the
lecture hall this translation therefore
enhances all other English
translations and that's amazing for Dr C
to say because um because of who he is
he has to hold by yis laav Pelicans
translations which are published by
Concordia but anyhow he goes on to say
which have delivered these lectures in
English up to this point since these
other translations have rendered the
similar but not identical text of the
edited version of the reformers great
lectures of
1531 that appeared in print four years
later that's
1535 here we encounter and now he's
referring to my translation here we
encounter what Luther said not what he
and his editors wished he had said or
thought he had meant to say and that's a
little bit of a dig on on all the other
translations I'm sad to say kamacho
takes us into the lecture hall to catch
the personal inflection that the
reformer brought to the exposition of
Paul's letter in the midst of increased
papal and Imperial pressure on the
Wittenberg theologians and their world
view in the wake of the diet of Augsburg
in
1530 the urgency of the reformers
exposition of the Gospel of the
restoration of human righteousness
through Christ's death and Resurrection
rings from the pages of this fresh
Lively rehearing of the lectures as
presented in the notes of the Wittenberg
professors students Robert
coob and every time I read this I sort
of Choke up because um it is so
incredible that such an amazing scholar
and historian uh would um would give
that kind of review of this particular
translation so between the Spanish and
the and the English
translation going back to the Latin
original because the Latin original of
their notes exists and you can find it
online um it was a a trip of about 10
years which did not start until my wife
Mercedes um said to me honey what you
need to do is translate the whole thing
don't be happy just to translate a few
Clips here and there and of course my
reaction was rather visceral like who do
you think I
am uh but uh her um gentle yet Earnest
um uh appeal uh slowly worked until one
day I just began on page one in Spanish
I wanted to do the translation first in
Spanish because there was no Spanish
translation uh of um of this commentary
and there was in French there was in
Italian there was of course in German uh
in English but there was no Spanish
translation available so that's why I
chose to do that one first and the first
translation I was
self-published no one wanted to
translate Luther's commentary on
Galatians uh they wanted uh five steps
to a happy Christian marriage um 10
commandments to bring up your children
they wanted practical
stuff so uh I had to um to self-publish
the first version of of the Spanish
commentary later um 1517 just up until
recently this year uh 2024 they
published the whole thing in Spanish
which I
revised and um they had an um an
editorial group go through the Spanish
and I I was very adamant with them
saying I don't want you to change the
register I I want this um very Dynamic
um Luther speaking from the classroom
and they did a great job in retaining
the same register and correcting some of
my Spanish grammar and so on so that's
the long answer to
um how and why I decided to translate
first the Spanish commentary and then
miles I didn't want to do the English I
said I'm done I'm burned out it's
over and and uh my wife said um you know
you need to start translating the and
translate it into English as well and uh
I
said no you know somebody else is going
to do
it again she won out and I started and I
was over 9
5% done with the English translation not
knowing who was going to publish this
document uh because I had sent chapters
to Concordia no
less and of course Concordia is very
jealous of its own published works and
this Concordia had published yis
Pelicans translation but it was not a
standalone book it was part of a whole
series um of of books um that Concordia
had
published there was not a modern
Standalone
translation and one day I wanted to
check on um on h a
date when um when Luther had first
dictated lectures on
Galatians because this is a second
series of lectures on gal
his first series had been translated
both into Spanish and into English and I
didn't remember whether it was 1519 or
1517 when he had published it so I go to
Google and I type
1517 and up comes
written on the Reformation because
that's her purpose to keep the
Reformation alive um send us a sample
copy of your of your book and we will
respond within the
month so I said ah it's the same thing
again you know they oh I I sent in a
chapter all dejected and depressed and
um you know not even hoping against hope
I just said okay I'm going to do it
three days later I get a phone call from
Stephen
Burns the chief editor of
1517 and he s he says to me send us
whatever you've got
done will'll will'll help you publish it
we'll help you polish it up and stuff
and that was
like God God saying I told
so and it was very exciting and of
course I worked with them for um about a
year in polishing it up um they gave me
some resources to check and um but uh it
was great to have them publish um the
commentary in English and of course it's
in a an ebook format as well as a hard
copy and a a soft copy which which is I
think the one you have so again that's
the longer answer to your
question so it came basically through uh
well Providence essentially and um
really the need for it I I know you
mentioned it a little bit earlier but
it's interesting because it it doesn't
really read like a commentary it reads
kind of more like a novel um it's a very
interesting um I have a lot of
commentaries and it's definitely unique
amongst the commentaries I have so I
highly highly recommend it to people
I've recommended it to a number of
people some who I know who have picked
it up and they have also thoroughly
enjoyed it as well so I will put a link
to that down in the description box so
people can uh quickly gain access to
that if that's something they're
interested in now with that as the
backdrop I want to look at something
from an introductory manuscript in the
commentary that's titled St Paul's
argument Luther writes quote in this
epistle Paul takes on the task of
diligently teaching comforting and
perfecting Us in the knowledge of this
most excellent Christian righteousness
for if we should lose the article of
justification then all true Christian
doctrine will be lost and everyone in
the world who does not hold on to this
Doctrine is either a Jew a Muslim a
follower of the Pope or a heretic
because between the righteousness of the
law and Christian righteousness there is
no halfway point whoever Strays from
this Christian righteousness inevitably
Falls into the righteousness of the law
in short once he loses Christ he must by
default fall into confidence of his own
Works close quote so Luther did not hold
back when it came to this Doctrine
because he believed that St Paul didn't
so my question for you since we're going
to be looking at this in light of
seventh day adventism I want to make
sure we really have nailed down what is
the New Testament doctrine of
justification and why is correctly
understanding it so important important
for the
Christian I cannot answer this without
the
scriptures and my goto scripture on
explaining this or understanding this is
Romans the book of um Romans chapter 4
and chapter 5 particularly verse one so
let me try to go through this quickly in
Romans um chapter 4 Paul makes an
astounding statement with regards to
Abraham and he begins to quote
Abraham um
as the one who believed God and then
verse
three it was credited to him as
righteousness now to the one who works
wages are not credited as a gift but as
an obligation of course you work you get
paid
so eternal life is given to you as a
wage but it says however to the one who
does not
work but trust God who
justifies the
ungodly their faith is credited as
righteousness and what I I find so
unusual about this statement is that if
you see verse five in the
context when Paul is talking about the
ungodly the the word there in the Greek
means without respect for anything
Divine whether it's Idols whether it's a
pagan worship of Idols uh whether it's
the Jewish worship of yve it is Asus
that means without any kind of piety the
person has that has no respect for
anything Divine and sort of flaunts
himself uh before the world surrounding
him as a great unbeliever you know like
you know I don't care and that ungodly
in context refers to
Abraham you catch my
drift it's not the general uh ungodly
out there but Paul is talking about
Abraham being this Godless
person as the one that God
justifies in other words um
Abraham is justified by
God merely by believing that this entity
in which he did not believe in had been
sort of you know just following because
he had been asked to leave and had had
strange uh visions and things so he
follows uh um God's word out of the land
of er of the calans and calans were
pagans
so he follows God and
then God says you will be given a seed
that will bless all the
nations and and and Abraham is marveled
how could this God who he really in his
heart does not fully believe in he could
care less about God he just wants a
better life
so he thinks he's going to find a better
life wherever this God who has spoken to
him is leading him but then this God
says to him through you all the nations
of the earth will be blessed and he
can understand this amount of grace and
mercy that he being ungodly
disrespectful of anything that has
anything to do with
piety
will work through
him to give the blessing of a
seed that will bring
blessings the ultimate blessing to all
the nations and Abraham believed God and
it was credited to him as
righteousness and that one act of
Mercy one over
Abraham's
heart so
justification is not geared looking at
justification from this text
justification is not geared towards the
obedient The Godly the pious the ones
who have years developing their
character who by faith grasp unto the
merits of Christ and work together and
cooperate together with God's Will and
the the will then becomes omnipotent
because he has worked with the Divine
will and so on and no not at all
justification is directed towards the
person that does not have one
ioda of any human righteousness to offer
God on his behalf so it's entirely given
uh to him I get I get passionate about
this and so the rest of the chapter
talks about uh Abraham being uh
Justified and then he uh Paul ends this
uh chapter with an incredible statement
he says that the words it was credited
to him were written not for him
alone but also for
us and there Paul is considering himself
also as an
assis for all practicable purpose and
all his time in Judaism and his called
by the Lord he still sees himself as a
sinner says but also for us he
himself in spite of all his work for the
Lord for the the Christ that appeared to
him and and his sufferings and
everything he has gone uh through he
says that I am like Abraham and I need
this
righteousness and it will and God will
then credit that righteousness for us
who believe in
him and then he says who raised Jesus
our lord from the dead he makes this
illusion to the resurrection because he
is going to nail it nail the the
important fact of the Resurrection he
explained the meaning of the
Resurrection in the next verse and this
is a verse that has not been properly
understood uh in in most Christian works
on
justification because Paul says he
meaning Christ was delivered over to
death on account of our
sins okay and then this last phrase and
was rais to
life for our justification
all the
translators you know I am a translator
and I have to double check
transations uh which is a very good
thing that happened to me throughout my
many years as a as a court interpreter
because you have other interpreters
listening to your translation and they
come and then they um take apart the
reason why you should not have
translated it this way but rather the
other way and you have to defend your
translation it's very good work but Paul
says that Christ was raised to life for
our justification if we leave it at for
our
justification we make a translation
error because it sounds as if Christ was
raised so that then he could um play the
role or function as our justifier that
then he was raised from the dead so that
then there could be a judgment by which
um let's call it the investigated
judgment in which he could see
somebody's life and uh that person's
obedience to the Commandments and then
say you're Justified and then somebody
comes up and has uh gez you know he
watched the two of the France on
Saturday and uh no the Angels bring to
Christ the book on which the day in
which you watched the tour of the FRS
and were reading for the tour for
whoever it was and uh the Lord says no I
cannot justify you yeah no no go to the
other side and so he was Christ was not
raised to do
this the translation for this text and I
hope I can land here on the on the the
right Trans on the right Greek text the
Bible hob Romans
4:25 you see where it says here he was
raised for the justification of us and
it translates this Greek preposition Dia
it translated translates it as for which
is a great error it's a great mistake
and changes the meaning of uh of the
verse Dia is a preposition that when
found in in the genitive it does mean
for okay but here it's not
modifying a a um a sentence in the
genitive but in the accusative you see
that V that looks like a V there is in
it's actually the Greek for n
tainos you see the again the ending it's
in the accusative and it tells you noun
accusative feminine feminine
singular um hum of us
okay so there it is accusative feminine
singular it's the article so Dia when it
modifies the remaining part the
remaining phrase where there's a
nominative phrase or an adverbial uh
phrase it
means because of it's
instrumental it means um literally he
was raised to give testimony of our
justification he was raised because we
had been
Justified and so when Christ is raised
from the dead he shouts
from all over the place throughout the
Universe miles Christian has been
justified through my death aralo kamacho
has been justified through my death he
does not raised from the dead to be our
justifier he is raised from the dead to
give witness that we have been justified
through his life death and
Resurrection so if you ask me what is
the doctrine what is the biblical
doctrine of justification I have to say
that my justification took place 2,000
years
ago and Christ has already given witness
to my
justification of course
theologians like to talk in terms of
objective and subjective justification
and they mess it up when they talk about
and let me tell you let me explain to
you why they mess it up because when we
go to Romans
51 we find this
phrase and then there is a comma
okay I am sorry there were no commas
in the
original okay it's that simple there
were no commas in the
original and if you look at various
translations of the Bible you will find
that the translators struggle with where
to place the
comma some
translate uh therefore
comma Justified by faith comma or
therefore having been Justified comma um
I think the the Spanish RV um version um
the Raina 1960 places about three commas
all over the place because they wanted
to make everybody else happy you know as
far as where the comma went and where
the comma goes is a big thing if you
take into account uh for 425 425 is very
explicit that he was raised to give
testimony Dia on account of the fact
that we had been Justified so he is
raised to give witness of our
justification and so the Apostle in
Romans 5 says having been Justified and
now in the Greek the first word of a
sentence is where the emphasis goes so
that's why Paul put the the first word
having been Justified it's a verb it's a
reflexive uh verb that has brings the
action back to us um having been
Justified
comma therefore by faith we have peace
with God through our Lord Jesus Christ
right so I ask what do we have by
faith once we have justif been Justified
at the cross and in his
resurrection what do we have by
faith we have peace with God and that's
why in another place uh Paul calls
Christ Our
peace so I am not justified twice as the
objective and subjective theologians
teach that yes all Humanity was
justified through his death but
individuals are not justified until
subjectively they
exerise individual faith in Christ's
work
no what we do is say amen that's the
meaning of
Faith amen comes from the Hebrew which
means this is true um even more it also
means it's a foundation it's a solid
foundation in the ancient times uh they
were building supervisors okay and when
they came to inspect the foundation
before the building was put up they went
all over that founding rock that
Cornerstone and and um HD it with
hammers and whatever to see if it would
crack and if the foundation was solid
the buildings supervisor would say Amen
they would say yes it is worthy it is a
um it will last the building of the
house or the temple or whatever so that
is all we say uh faith means I believe
that you did it I say Amen Christ says
uh from the uh risen um open Tomb he
says I have Justified
youu and I say amen I say yes I believe
it I have faith that what you did was
done and what is given to me is not
justification what is given to me
is um
peace with God and that's why Christ
said uh my peace I leave with you not as
the world gives give I unto you that is
the kind kind of peace I give to you let
not your heart be
troubled uh because we have been given a
historical Moment On which to Anchor our
peace and that historical moment is his
death and his resurrection and he has
given witness through his resurrection
that we have been Justified and thus I
have peace with God and not and it's a
peace that won't be taken away that's
why it's a peace that um is not given as
the world gives because the peace that
the world gives to me even the
righteousness of the law the peace that
I get through the righteousness of the
law lasts as long as my next misstep or
bad thought or bad judgment or whatever
I do I lose my peace we do not lose this
peace because it is grounded and
anchored to to the rock well that's
probably more than an answer that you
wanted to get uh on uh on the difference
uh as far as you know biblical
justification no that's good um you know
I'm kind of getting some some hints
there of uh that old Latin phrase of
simal Justice at picor um this sort
of Sinner while still Justified um and
that is really just music to my ears so
I could sit there and just listen to you
talk about that um nonstop but something
I think that's just as important to
understand in relation to this subject
that I think often times gets left
behind or is just not properly
understood by most um Christians is what
is the law gospel distinction and why is
understanding that necessary to properly
understand what you just explained
okay um again I could go to Luther on
this because that is one of his favorite
subject in the commentary but in U in a
certain section he simplifies
it uh he
says law is
anything that you give to God with your
hands okay anything whether it was Moses
law the requirements of the prophets and
even Jesus own teachings that
require uh great deep spiritual Behavior
Uh that is also
law so that is how he explained what the
law is is anything that God asks of you
and you give to God
but the gospel is when you open your
hands and your hand hands are empty and
then you receive from
Christ the fullness of his righteousness
imputed to
you but you must bring your hands empty
even
dirty because you cannot receive the
fullness of Christ's gift of his
righteousness if there is anything left
over in your hands to give no matter how
Pious no matter how
dedicated uh your profession of faith is
no matter what your Sabbath keeping is
no matter what you know second or third
tithe or whatever you do with your tithe
or with your money no matter how great a
life you have lived you cannot even
offer one molecule of that to God of
course Luther didn't use molecule he
just said you cannot put anything in
your hands in order to receive the gift
of justification so he said and I'm
going back to Luther Luther said as you
read the
scripture learn to
distinguish what is Law and what is
Gospel don't stop at the Old Testament
stop in the Book of
Revelation and then gospel is where you
are offered the grace and the mercy of
God and the two are as far from the East
as another one is from the West you
cannot co-mingle law and gospel so as to
make uh your
hands full of Law and at the same time
think that you are receiving gospel um
Luther said U these two cannot lie on
the same
bed he um quotes either Isaiah or
Jeremiah uh where they ask him to lie on
the same bed uh no the beds are too
narrow you can only have and he and and
Luther refers as to the conscience you
can either have the law rule your
conscience or the gospel in your
conscience saying to you
peace you have been forgiven through the
fullness of Christ's imputed
righteousness and through his death
which is your death which conquered your
death through his resurrection so that
is basically the the uh how to
distinguish law and Grace and he says
very interestingly for someone who had a
doctorate degree uh Luther said whoever
can read read scripture making this
distinction between law and
Grace is a theologian it's
amazing so yeah that's very
simplified the the difference between
law and and Grace and and the gospel
yeah yeah we've looked at that quote a
number of times I talk about the subject
a lot um I typically show um just
because I think it's a great summation
statement I typically look at Lewis
birkoff's Systematic Theology where he
essentially quotes Luther and he's he
quotes that same thing but um the most
succinct way would be that the law says
doe and the gospel says done yeah um and
that there is a a stark contrast here
and I find that a lot of Adventists
really struggle with this if they really
understood the law gospel distinction it
would clear up 95% of the theological
problems I've identified with adventism
it's because they don't understand how
to distinguish between law and gospel
despite the fundamental beliefs book
claiming that they do um we're going to
look at a little bit of that later I
don't want to get too ahead of myself um
but I I just say that because I think
it's so important for them to really
study and understand and try to grasp
this it's really like a hermeneutical
principle it's a way that you look at
scripture when we say law there we're
not talking about just the Ten
Commandments we're talking about when
you're reading the Bible the big one for
them is Matthew 548 they love to go
there and say well you we were just
looking at Luther on this uh a few weeks
ago actually um in his commentary on
Matthew 5 and uh how they love to say
well Jesus said be ye perfect as your
father in Heaven is perfect well right
but he's expounding upon the law he's
not telling you there how you can be
made right with God that's not gospel
that's law that's him expounding upon
the law so we will get into more of that
in a little bit but a couple more
questions before we transition to the
SDA examination um and it kind of
dovetails perfectly off of what we were
just talking about what is the
relationship between justification and
sanctification
again the gospel is
extravagant there is the saying and I'm
sorry I maybe getting ahead of my of of
of where you're going by uh referencing
seventh day
adventism but uh uh throughout um high
school and college and the
Seminary I was taught that you have to
have a balance
between Christ's work for us and
Christ's work in US Christ's work for us
is
justification and Christ uh uh work in
US is
sanctification and we grow in
sanctification and you remember the
lines that were drawn that uh Christ's
righteousness comes up to this point and
thereafter you are growing in
sanctification and until you surpass
somehow Christ's righteousness and then
you become so perfect you are living
without an intercessor and you know that
kind of thing and So eventually when
Adventists talk about sanctification and
justification um
sanctification always preempts
justification
um justification is never complete
without your justif ification God can
never declare you righteous until you
are made
righteous um so uh I go to First
Corinthians Paul says and because of him
you are in Christ
Jesus once we are in Christ Jesus and we
get there through justification
um who he has become it it says this
particular version says who became to us
putting it in the
past wisdom from God
righteousness and
sanctification and
Redemption and the
way that one resolves this tension that
not only adventism but other Evangelical
faiths and Pentecostal faiths and many
other um even some Lutheran faiths try
to resolve this uh is through the growth
and sanctification they may not say that
we eventually outgrow or go past Christ
righteousness and
justification but sanctification is the
work of a lifetime and you know you go
at it you repent of your sins and then
you know you you keep on growing in this
thing called sanctification and it's
interesting because sanctification means
nothing that you're set apart for a
special purpose but what I see here in
First Corinthians 1:10 is that all of
these are
imputed the righteousness of Christ is
imputed it's called
justification sanctification is also
imputed to to us at the beginning of our
work with
Christ we already we're already seen as
totally
Sanctified because the imputed
righteousness of Christ cannot do
anything else if you are declared
righteous you're also declared holy
Sanctified and you have also been
declared redeemed or risen with Christ
so all of these are
imputed uh our
sanctification does not add one bit of
Holiness to what is already ours in
Jesus
Christ so there is nothing to talk about
when it comes about the relationship
between sanctify ification and
justification in what one does and what
the other one does um it is all imputed
to us the the work of um Christ is so
complete at the cross and at the
resurrection that his
righteousness can no longer demand from
us a
righteousness that has already been
counted or credited to our
account what happens is that the Holy
Spirit then
says I've got this kid called
kamacho and I know all his defects and I
know all his stuff and uh but I will be
a father to him I will be his guide I
will be with him in in whatever he gets
into to and I will pull him out and he
will learn from that because I will be
his teacher I will comfort him because
he is our comforter and I have work for
him to do because uh we are uh given
Grace and uh once we are given Grace we
are saved by grace um we were we are
shown we are given works that were um
designed for us
from
beforehand and that's why sometimes we
are amazed how one thing in our lives
clicks toward the other like how did
this happen how did I happen to call
1517 which was out out of my doubts and
frustration I call 1517 to see if
they're going to publish Luther's
commentary so all these things seem to
be fitting together and I don't
understand why why do not understand why
did it come
about because these are
Works made designed for us to walk in
them
beforehand but there's nothing about
Sabbath keeping there's nothing about
life paying there's nothing about all
this uh because those things get in the
way of whatever God has planned out for
us we cannot complete God's will for us
in the works he has designed for us if
we insist on God no your works for me
are 10 or
whatever um so um yeah that is how I uh
I see this whole issue of justification
and and
sanctification yeah that's good it's
interesting because um you know I'm I'm
often times poking around in Adventist
archives looking and reading
documentation looking for claims that
the scholars are making and those types
of things and uh this could be a whole
discussion in and of itself but um
there's a pocket of SDA scholarship
um early 2000s up to the the modern day
maybe sooner than that but were there're
on this big kick that really the
Adventist understanding of justification
it's no different than early Martin
Luther they actually believe the same
thing Martin Luther did and I don't know
how familiar you are with um The Finnish
school um but they appeal to some of
these um Lutheran Finnish Scholars um
who who kind of try and support that but
there's just an interesting history
there around the why they would appeal
to The Finnish school which is I would
argue um somewhat of like a historically
revised understanding of Luther but I
just think it's interesting that they
they try to appeal to him of all people
to try and really bolster their idea of
justification namely with what they
believe about justification and
sanctification being tied together which
we're going to look at in a moment but I
got one final question before we
transition to that I want I want to read
a quote from Ken Sund Jones's book a
Lutheran toolkit which is a great little
book that is also published by
1517 he writes quote Luther used two
pairs of words that can help us
understand what's going on here active
and passive righteousness active
righteousness is the goodness that comes
about because of what we do this is the
righteousness that Luther struggled with
in the medieval interpretation of the
phrase the righteousness of God passive
righteousness though is a right
that is foreign to you it is a
righteousness that comes apart from
anything you do it's given to you placed
in you without your having done a lick
of work to make it happen such
righteousness comes as a gift close
quote so we get a little bit here of
what um to me sounds like what Lutheran
often refer to as like an extra NOS um
it's salvation coming completely from
outside of ourselves so so can you
elaborate further on the differences
between passive and active
righteousness let me read to you um what
uh what Paul wrote In what Paul what
Luther wrote in this uh
respect now this is again from uh my
translation of
um of Luther's um epistle um Luther's
commentary to the Galatians
when he writes about the M main argument
of the
epistle what did Paul intend to do with
this epistle now as you read through
this I think you will see the answer to
your question St Paul proposes to
establish the doctrine of Faith Grace
the Forgiveness of sins or Christian
righteousness so that we may perfectly
understand the difference between
Christian righteous and all other types
of
righteousness there is a political or
civil righteousness that's the first one
Emperors the princes of this world
philosophers and attorneys must deal
with this one there is also a
righteousness of social behavior
according to human
Traditions parents as well as tutors May
teach this type of righteousness without
fear
hence they do not attribute to these
types of actions any satisfaction for
sin to please God or to Merit Grace so
if you teach your kid right manners to
greet people correctly uh Etc uh this is
not done in any way satisfaction for
sin they teach that these types of
behaviors are only necessary to correct
bad habits and certain observances
regarding social life now
notice parallel to these there is
another righteousness called the
righteousness of the law or the Ten
Commandments taught by Moses according
to the doctrine of faith we also teach
this one it's amazing how
Luther places The Ten Commandments on
the same level as the righteousness of
uh good manners and good social graces
it's
incredible
however there is another above all
others namely the righteousness of Faith
or Christian
righteousness we must diligently tell
this one apart from the others this last
one opposes the others a great deal
the first types of righteousness flow
from the laws of the Emperors the
traditions of the Pope and the
Commandments of
God they also consist in our good works
and can be done by us through our sheer
natural effort as the papists say or
even as a gift from God
yes the keeping of the Ten
Commandments in our best possible way is
a gift from from God all these types of
righteousness are gifts of God as well
as other good things that we
enjoy
but this more excellent righteousness
can you imagine Luther saying this in
class the passion with which he's
speaking to his students this more
excellent righteousness that I say is of
faith is this God through Christ apart
from any work of our own put said freely
to our account and there you can find a
whole bunch of verses in texts in
Ephesians in Romans in Galatians that
you could use to support that particular
particular Romans 4 as we as we saw it
this righteousness is not political or
behavioral it is not the righteousness
of the law of God did you catch that and
I'm asking this to the hearer this is is
not the righteousness of the law of God
it does not concern our works but exists
on a different level it is simple it is
a simple passive
righteousness see since all the previous
ones are
active see the difference
there if you want to be active there's a
whole bunch of stuff that you can be
active
with but as far as getting right with
God it is the passive righteousness we
are passive we don't work for
it it is a simple passive righteousness
since all previous ones are active to
obtain this one we don't do any work at
all nor do we offer anything to God
rather we only receive and allow another
to work in our have none other than God
himself this is the righteousness that
Luther called the alien righteousness
the extranos righteousness it's the
alien righteousness of Christ that is
Christ that is credited to our account
therefore it has seemed right to me to
call this passive
righteousness the righteousness of Faith
or Christian righteousness he goes on
this righteousness is a hidden Mystery
the world is not aware of it what's more
Christians themselves don't understand
it fully and they can hardly take hold
of it in their
Temptations therefore it is necessary to
teach it and practice it continually
without any letup and whoever can't
understand it or is unable to hold on to
this righteousness will be hounded by
the con Conant fears of his conscience
and will certainly be defeated there is
no other comfort as firm and sure for
the conscience as is offered by this
passive righteousness and I'm jumping
down to this bottom paragraph there is
no
medication for the mortified and
perturbed conscience when it is under
condemnation of Eternal death it must
take hold of the promise of Grace
offered in Christ Jesus that is unless
it takes hold of this passive
righteousness or Christian righteousness
if it's able to grasp it then the
conscience will find rest it will
trustingly say I don't seek this act of
righteousness or the righteousness of
works even though I know I must also
have it and fulfill it but even if I had
it and fulfilled it without a doubt even
so I could not trust it neither could I
bring it as a defense against J God's
judgment therefore I will strip myself
of all act of righteousness mine as well
as that of God's law and embrace only
this passive righteousness the
righteousness of Grace based on God's
mercy and his forgiveness of sins in
summary I find rest only on this
righteous
that is the righteousness of Christ and
the Holy Spirit we don't produce it but
we submit to Bear it it is not found
within us but we receive it as a gift
from God the Father through Jesus Christ
notice this last phrase is in italics
which was left out from the first
English translation
s amazing so and it's also amaz amazing
that he says we submit to barit because
generally we use the term submit to God
surrender yourselves to God uh so that
you will be justified or That You Will
Be Loved or that you will be guided by
God but here Luther changes that around
and says that this passive righteous
righteousness is one that we submit to
Bear it it's amazing because we usually
submit so that we can do active uh
righteousness but here he says submit to
Bear the passive righteousness of Christ
because your first instinct will be to
cast it off and produce active
righteousness to be right with God so so
again um that is the the long context
for um this Ken sundel Jones from the
Lutheran
toolkit where where Luther got this from
it's from nowhere else but from the
righteousness of Christ that was
fulfilled on our our behalf um yeah
amazing stuff this commentary just um
never there no page in which you cannot
find a
gem yeah it's good stuff it's like a
spiritual jacuzzi you know it's just
like ah it's just so you know again
basking in the goodness of the Gospel um
but I want to summarize here just for
the audience um and make it very very
plain and very clear um the teaching of
Paul the Apostle when it comes to
justification is that a sinner can be
made right with a holy God strictly on
the basis of the person and work of
Jesus Christ that's what the gospel is
the person and work of Christ salvation
comes entirely outside of ourselves and
is received by faith that's essentially
what we're getting at here so in light
of that now I want to examine some
Adventist statements and some Adventist
teaching on this and see if it truly
does align with what we just put forth
first let's look at a quote from a paper
titled justification by faith in
Adventist understanding
this is a paper that was written by a
former SDA Professor by the name of
Peter Van Beman he writes quote
Adventists have always perceived
themselves as Heirs of the great truths
recovered and proclaimed by the
Protestant
reformers as stated in the concluding
report of another bilateral dialogue
Adventists have a high appreciation for
the Reformation they see themselves as
HS of Luther and other reformers
especially in their adherence to the
great principles of solos script
solar gratia Sola and solo
chisto this plac is Adventist in harmony
with the traditional Evangelical
understanding of justification by faith
and also with the patristic tradition
for according to Thomas Odin the major
reformers appeals to solos scriptura
solar gratia and solop are found
abundantly in the patristic interpreters
of scripture close quote so according to
Mr van bemin the Church considers itself
to be an heir of the reformation and
they are in line with the Reformation
understanding of justification by faith
before looking at his practical
explanation of their understanding
brother you are now a Lutheran lay
Minister former SDA Pastor was this your
experience in the Seventh Adventist
Church yes not not only the experience
but it was the teaching uh because uh
sometimes Adventist professors uh
particularly Marvin mvin
Maxwell uh you know he was one of the
kids of um Arthur Maxwell who wrote the
Bible
stories he he taught the moral influence
Theory together with Jack
provancha mvin Maxwell who taught
several courses at the Seminary when I
was there would wax eloquently on uh on
Luther and U at times would want to get
carried away on justification by faith
but he he he would catch himself at the
last minute and would add Works would
add the Adventist message of the
understanding of justification by faith
as if
there as if we needed the Adventist
understanding but anyhow it was very
interesting because he
and others blinko in particular and I
have mentioned blinko and Tom bleno in
my past uh interview with you they would
say that we stood on the shoulders of
the
reformers
but we would ask them and I remember the
hands raised and the questions various
questions on this um how
come
Luther didn't teach the
Sabbath and didn't teach
1844 and there you could hear a pin drop
after that
question so I don't remember which
whether was Blanco or Maxwell or both
who would come up with an answer like
this with this smile on their face
saying
those
truths were
reserved for the remnant Church of today
to
Proclaim it was the will of God to
reserve those
truths for us Brethren and for you
students to take those teachings to the
world the Reformation was not given
those truths so that the remnant church
today
would be the one to fill out the great
truths of the
Reformation including the great truth of
the spirit of Prophecy and the special
Revelation given to us through and then
white and this time the room would
remain just a still you could hear a pin
drop and I don't know if it was because
the rest of the students as well as
myself were wondering wow that was a
pretty good
out but through the passing of time I
came to realize that yes the Adventist
Church not only climbed on the shoulders
of the reformers but actually crushed
the shoulders of the
reformers and um stood all over them uh
stomped them
out moved them to the side and then
substituted everything that belonged to
the reformers with their conflict of the
AG of series their Remnant Church idea
this whole madeup
story thus they Crush their actual work
is crush the reformation and this whole
thing about soles scriptura my
goodness that is such a slight of hand
and I call it a slight of hand because
what advinus do is that they sneak this
term the spirit of Prophecy they sneak
it in scripture and inside the terms uh
spirit of Prophecy in in fact the term
is found in scripture but they sneak
inside the term the name Ellen
White so they stick it in there and then
they
say with with this innocent face St a
scriptura when they already know what
they have
done they have perverted scripture by
taking this term of scripture the spirit
of
Prophecy and inserted their own gloss
gloss their own understanding of the
spirit of Prophecy to mean Ellen white
and whole conflict of the ages series
the whole thing and then they have the
go the face to say we are only Sola
scriptura we are the true
reform and you know to that I say
kabat iabat which means the glory has
departed in fact there was no glory to
begin with but whatever Glory there was
as far as Adventist
theology it it it is
blasphemy to to say that that that uh
you pervert scripture and then you are
truly understanding scripture and you
know they um I also remembered one of
those teachers again I don't remember it
was blinko or Maxwell maybe uh per
chance there there is some um student my
age I just turned 75 miles I just turned
75 maybe there's some other student my
age from back then who was sitting in
those classrooms and could correct me
but uh I remember these discussions and
these statements by these teachers
saying oh I am sure Luther if he had
known what we know today he would have
followed the Sabbath
truth yes he was he came very
close to understanding the Sabbath
truth and they would say it with such
conviction that we innocent p
seminarians would say wow God has spoken
so you ask me about my understanding and
an experience in the seven the Adventist
Church yeah until Walter Ray came along
and opened up the can of
worms no there was a diet of worms and
then there is raised can of
worms and out of the can of worms come
out all these great
authors who sister white copied sister
white copied oh the um in in Spanish
they call it the pluma de inspir The
Inspired pen there you go there's the
English term there the inspired
pen so uh yeah that was my understanding
of what this was going on but initially
as a seminarian uh we were very
vulnerable to these statements and we
believed them and uh we said yeah okay I
am the Fulfillment of the Reformation
yeah so they've been saying this for for
quite some time now notice what Dr Van
ban goes on to then write in the paper
he says quote if our justification is
through grace alone by faith alone does
The Obedience of Faith have anything to
do with our Salvation or to phrase the
question differently do our thoughts
words and actions play a role in
determining our Eternal destiny
these are crucial questions which are
closely related to the issue of the
final
judgment scripture has much to say about
that judgment not least in the teachings
of Our Lord as recorded in the gospels
said Jesus I tell you that men will have
to give account on the day of judgment
for every careless word they've spoken
for by your words you will be acquitted
the RSV and the new King James say
Justified and by your words you will be
condemned here our Lord talks about
justification and condemnation the
judicial Declarations of innocence and
guilt in the context of the day of
judgment obviously there is an
eschatological aspect to
justification Adventists believe on the
basis of scripture that the day of
judgment is a very comprehensive concept
and much Adventist literature has been
published on the subject close quote so
here he explains a two- tiered system of
justification that you're initially
justified by grace through faith but to
be determined in the future will be your
eschatological justification a second
justification which is ultimately
determined by your thoughts words deeds
and motives and this is where
sanctification comes in Ellen White has
that famous quote where she says
justification is your title for heaven
but sanctification is your Fitness for
heaven but the support that he appeals
to for this from scripture is Matthew
through
37 is what he described consistent with
the Reformation teaching on
justification well I think Luther would
ask him where did you get your
degree you don't deserve a degree since
you cannot separate law and
gospel what Christ was doing was an
amazing use of the law and again Luther
does not Cast Away the law the law say
he says that the law has this very
specific function and that is to enter
our hearts and make us shake so that we
will trust only in his righteousness and
not in
ours Matthew 12:36 and
37 is law as taught by Christ himself in
order to make the uh the
self-righteous and whoever thinks that
he is pious to stand in the Judgment
shake and flee to Christ again but they
don't understand this seven day
Adventists must stand on their own
righteousness in the Judgment oh they
say it's not our own righteousness it is
the righteousness that has been imparted
to us and Ellen White has this i' you
know I've been it's been a while since
I've read a whole lot of Ellen White but
she says that that it is like a fiber or
a text
that is woven in and through us it is
nothing but Roman Catholic Doctrine and
if you like we can get into this but
Adventist must always come to um the
word judgment they like to drag The
Sinner the guilty sinner into judgment
and they say you are guilty therefore
you must keep the
Commandments which is an oximoron
because the Commandments will do nothing
else but say you're even more
guilty so anytime you talk about
justification and Grace Adventist will
drag you back to
SI and say you must you know like
Nehemiah grab you by the beard and grab
you by the
hair and say you must obey the law of
the
Lord and this is what this gentleman is
doing he um he is taking us back to
Sinai by quoting The Words of Christ
himself and Luther himself says this in
this commentary that many take even the
admonitions of Christ as orders to go
back to SI and keep the law of Moses and
therefore bring
back um bring back to the conscience uh
all kinds of um lack of peace all kinds
of doubts and anguish back to the
conscience and that is not the purpose
of justification if justification has
not brought you the complete sense that
your sins all your sins past present and
future have been forgiven through the
death of Christ then uh justification
has done nothing for you I I'm reminding
of that wonderful text you know when I
was um
a a a pastor I'd like to say a young
Pastor um but I must have been what
35ish back then when um and I know the
last time I was on your uh on your
channel uh on your interview people
wrote says oh I get it why kamacho is a
heretic or a dissident or something like
that if he was a pupil of
brims
then then I understand why uh he has
betrayed God's true church or something
like that there was a comment like that
that I read um but I am going to um go
to my experience with brims me and I
have no idea why eventually Brin me went
the direction he went with you know
that's his thing that is you know uh I I
can't get into his head but I remember a
text that he used to use over and over
over again in his lectures and I
listened to them in some and to other
lectures I went in um
disguised with an overcoat and dark
glasses and whatnot so that I would not
be discovered that I had been at brims
me lectures okay so I remember brims me
uh quoting Psalm
1432 and wish I could uh mimic his
Australian accent enter not into
judgment with thy servant for before
thee no flesh shall be
justified and he would say that the
sinner play is constantly not to be
taken into
judgment because no one could ever be
declared righteous when and brought to
judgment before God but adventism
opposes scripture and says Sinners you
must be brought to
judgment and like a parent upset with a
kid will pull him by the ear and take
him to the cookie jar and say it has
your fingerprints all over
it so you're
guilty and Adventist must constantly go
back to the Judgment as this gentleman
has
gone but scripture has the sinner
pleading there is no way I can win out
in the Judgment with any of my
Works they are faulty and Luther even
says of love we canot even bring love
because Adventist say oh we uh we
believe in justification by faith but
then because of our love of having been
Justified then we keep the
law it's a faulty defective love that
doesn't stand up to the kind of love you
must have and Luther used to say that
not even love can be brought into the
definition of justification because we
could ever love
more and when we think we love more the
law says You must love more you must
forgive more you must be more and more
patient so the law is always asking for
more and more
and our plea is enter
not into judgment with thy
servant for before thee no
flesh shall be justified so anyhow
that's um that's how I see this
gentleman's um turn into judgment my
goodness uh yeah but I understand where
he's coming from you know that's that's
what he was taught and that's what he
gets paid to say I don't know if he is a
retired Professor or what he is but yeah
he he is retired um it's just again
there's just so many things with this
quote here it's like it goes back to
what we were saying earlier about if you
don't understand the law gospel
distinction you will end up wielding the
law unlawfully and engaging in spiritual
murder you know totally just putting a
crushing weight on people when the whole
purpose of the law like you described is
to point a person to the gospel that's
the proper use you know and if you're
not getting accused of being an
antinomian like Luther did um are you
really preaching the gospel um because
the gospel is so
um it's just so contrary to what to to
your flesh to say it's that simple
really it's it's it's that it's that
good it's that easy yes it is and the
whole purpose of the law is to to point
us to that and Ellen White has a famous
quote where she says that the purpose of
the law is to point us to Christ which
is like okay amen but then she says
where you're shown the scars in his
hands to show you that the law is
immutable and then after you come to him
in faith after seeing what he did for
you he'll give you a new new found
ability and he points you back to the
law to now be able to do what the law
demands and it's just H it's just it's
that's what that's what Luther says the
Heretics do yeah the the schar Mary or
the enthusiasts who he called the
sectarians he used to say that he and
the gospel preachers would lead Sinners
to
Calvary but once the Sinners were in
Calvary thear Mary the the um Enthusiast
of the law would come to Calvary and
then they would tell the Sinners you
know we've got a better place for you
and lead them back to SI yeah that's
adventism and condemnations of sin yeah
and that's that's exactly adventism it's
just like oh my goodness it's like so
close yet completely just so far off but
what Peter Van bemin basically described
in this paper is the medieval
soteriology of the Middle Ages the the
exact thing this two-tiered system of
justification um where the reformers
were essentially arguing against that
that's essentially what solop is in the
context of is this distinction between a
two-tiered system of justification
intermingled with sanctification where
there's this initial you know Grace
that's given and you're Justified but
then depending on what happens down the
road that will determine this later
justification now notice what Ellen
White says on this subject which is
really what Dr Van bmlin is getting at
in that paper in her book faith and
works she writes quote while God can be
just and yet justify The Sinner through
the merits of Christ no man can cover
his soul with the garments of Christ's
righteousness while practicing known
sins or neglecting known duties God
requires the entire surrender of the
heart before justification can take
place and in order for man to retain
justification there must be continual
obedience through active Living Faith
that works by love and purifies the soul
close quote so through your obedience in
her context that's obedience to the law
you retain your
justification and that's what will
determine if you receive the
eschatological justification that we
just read about we will see why it has
to be this way in their system in a
moment but my question for you why is
what she said so
problematic well it goes against
scripture it goes against the scripture
um teaching on the Assurance of
Salvation that um we are uh complete and
we are accepted in the Beloved and that
acceptance is not conditional on our
continual surrender of What Not and this
and that and it's also problematic
because as Luther used to say because
this has been taught for by Heretics
throughout history and Luther had he not
like you said at the beginning he not
only had to deal with the uh false
teachings of U of Rome on justification
and I wish we had time to get to those
quickly uh but also with the
sectarians and um you know the
sectarians have always um brought um
back the law and push the law in the
believer's uh face and if this is true
Luther used to say in his lectures and
you will find it there in the
commentary know since I was sitting in
the back
row uh he would
ask show me the person that has this
kind of continued obedience to the law
and he would say and these
Hypocrites will not raise their
hand they talk about obedience to the
law and and continual surrender to God's
Will and perfect obedience and all this
stuff that that uh jeez I can't believe
that you know this stuff um allegedly
forms part of a Christian denomination
this is so unchristian is unbelievable
but yet I must be understanding because
I was there once upon a time I believed
this stuff and I tried to live it in my
heart and it was that which brought me
to faith in Christ the law um did meet
its purpose uh in me because God knows
how tried I had I how hard I tried to be
perfect in thought in action in love and
every I was going neurotic I was going
crazy when in col I had to go see a
psychiatrist because of this
stuff I was going neurotic I was going
crazy oh I to all appearances I I was
the great uh um um the theology major on
campus but inside I was a wreck I was
having uh all kinds of nervous symptoms
I couldn't sleep and uh it was horrible
because precisely of this kind of stuff
now many people don't take it seriously
but those Adventists that do take this
stuff
seriously if we could only read their
therapists um um
notes not only Adventists but also
church
leaders believe me there are a lot of
church leaders today in the Adventist
Church that warm the therapist couch
weekly so that they can deal with this
stuff so yeah
um I cannot you know I just this stuff
makes
me really
stick to my uh in my head and in my
stomach I can't handle this stuff it it
is so um destructive to a person's peace
with God and of course having been
Justified we have peace according to
this no one can be justified if you read
it
carefully no one can be justified yeah
it's crazy it's like like we just saw in
in the beginning of his paper it's like
Adventists believe in the great truths
of the reformers you know including
solid and then you read through the rest
of the paper and it's like well here's
why we've been accused of not being able
to affirm solid and they go to give
these long defenses part of which we're
going to look at now but then you see
what Ellen White says there in very
plain English and literally what she
describes is completely contrary to the
doc the Reformation doctrine of Sola it
is the same medieval soteriology that
the reformers were coming out of and
believed deviated from what script
teaches it is a two-tiered system of
justification you're initially Justified
and they'll say oh it's all by Grace it
is all by Grace yeah that initial
justification you're talking about which
in adventism is basically just given a
clean slate but then moving forward it's
to be
determined which is why that whole title
for heaven and fitness for heaven thing
well the title to Heaven means nothing
if you don't have the Fitness in their
model so really it's it's irrelevant
because they'll love to say no we
believe believe in the imputed
righteousness of Christ we believe in
the imputation of Christ's righteousness
but at the end of the day that means
nothing because what really matters in
the model is the gradual impartation in
little spurts of Christ righteousness
that you essentially receive in
accordance with your Obedience of trying
to keep the law that's not in accordance
with the Reformation doctrine of Sol
Aid you know the reformation and in fact
Luther talks about this in the
commentary and you may remember that in
in my last interview I did not want to
get into Luther's
commentary because I didn't want anybody
to say oh he's a Lutheran he's this and
he's that and you know now he has Luther
as his last word uh but Luther in his
commentary talks about this two-tiered
system and it it was called um medus de
conru and Meritus
Theo uh a merito the conru is an
initial approval of God because even
though you are a
sinner uh you see a beggar at the corner
of the
church um all in shattered clothes and
dirty and somewhere deep within you you
um begin saying okay I have a quarter I
have a dollar bill I have a penny or a
penny I will give the beggar a penny so
you take out a penny and you put it in
the uh Beggar's cup now Medi evil
salvation Theory or theology said that
when you have done such a deed it is
congruent to God's mercy you have done
something corresponding to God's
nature who is
merciful um
therefore God is
obliged to give you an initial Merit
because you have done something
according to God's
nature and with that Merit to the congru
that with that congruent Merit next week
then you will um you will leave a
quarter instead of a
penny and so you will keep on getting
these initial merits of
congruence until you walk through the
church and you come in and you take Mass
uh and now what God gives you is a
Meritus
Theo a merit to the condo is a merit
which God gives to you because you are
worthy before God because now you are
walking in the sacraments of the church
so we would equal this to the initial
merits as justification but then you
must make yourself worthy before God by
earning these U merits of worthiness or
Merit of condo and you keep on growing
through the various sacraments of the
church and receiving more and more
because what God does the way God gives
you these merits are through what uh
Roman Catholic theology calls to this
day they call infused
Grace by which the virtues and the
powers of Christ are infused into your
soul and and begin to fill your love
your soul with love so that you will
become more and more worthy before
God um and then eventually there will
come a time when you will be worthy
enough for you to be
justified yeah and obviously Adventists
are going to disagree on saying well no
no no no see we disagree with Merit
that's exactly what Peter Van bemin for
example says in his paper I've heard
that from countless other Adventists but
that's not the only problem at the end
of the day you still have the same
fundamental model you have a two-tiered
system and it really is coming down to
and I would argue adventism is really
synergism on steroids um it's not
monistic in any sense of the the the
word I actually had an Adventist
recently tried to tell me no no no you
don't even understand Adventist theology
I'm an Adventist seminarian right now
and we believe in synergistic
monergism okay yeah so they're coming up
with all sorts of fancy you know ways to
try and say but at the end of the day
it's not the the point being is it's not
like he said in the paper that they
affirmed the the Reformation doctrine of
solid they they just don't so Dr Van bin
one final question here for you because
he's actually going to explain why Ellen
would have said what she just did there
about justification must be retained
through your active obedience he writes
quote suffice it to say here that they
talking about Adventist hold that the
judgment is to be distinguished in an
investigative and an executive judgment
it is our belief in investigative
judgment that has led to the accusation
that we as Adventists he says they do
not really believe in the Reformation
principle of solid solar gratia close
quote so the avenus understanding of
this teaching solid or justification by
faith is impacted by their unique and do
and novel doctrine of the investigative
judgment which means that one must
understand that teaching to understand
what the da a church means when they
emphatically you know State no no we
believe justification by faith 1888 we
we got it right in 1888 justification by
faith final
question why is the investigative
judgment not compatible with the
Biblical teaching on
justification because it makes your
justification contingent or your
sanctification that's what the
investigative judgment is all about and
uh sanctification is your growth in
Grace is the same thing as the medit Deo
by which um Adventists don't use infused
Grace they use imparted righteousness it
is the same thing uh and that's how you
come before the the Judgment you've got
to have uh a pretty you know
100% um impartation of all of Christ's
righteousness as shown through
you uh as you have demonstrated it and
when you come into the investigative
judgment uh what in in then they misuse
um fully clothed in the garments of
Christ's righteousness but what they
mean by that is not that you are wearing
Christ's righteousness as a robe given
to you
without any Merit without any sense of
condition or worthiness but it's a robe
that you have woven with your own
hands and that is nothing but heresy
that is taking away the glory of God and
they break the Commandment that says
Thou shalt not
steal because the whole teaching of the
investigative judgment is is that you
must come in with your own gloriously
built Adam and Eve like uh style like
the way they put together their Garment
of righteousness to appear before God
that's their
teaching except that you must do a
better job than Adam and Eve in in doing
their
garment you must have followed Christ's
perfect example in thought and so on you
know and it brings me to Psalm 24 where
the psalmist ask you know in the final
um when in the final accounting of
things who shall stand before the Throne
of God and then it says he who has Clean
Hands and a pure heart he whose heart
has not
risen to um the Hebrew says to Bubbles
to follow after bubbles um to
vanity and it's very interesting that uh
the question is asked in the
singular uh he who has Clean
Hands prophetically and speaking uh
messianically of our Lord Jesus Christ
for he is the only one who has ever
stood before God with Clean Hands and a
pure heart and we stand before God given
that righteousness without any
righteousness of Our Own
because if we had one Fiber One
molecular fiber of our own
righteousness um it it would mess up God
would not recognize it we have tainted
the perfect righteousness of Christ so
that's why this this whole thing here um
about
um yeah the the
Reformation it leads where it says in it
is there belief in an investigative
judement that has led to the accusation
that they do not really believe in the
Reformation principle
ofia and I would say like many teenagers
say today
da does that surprise
you I mean you asked for
it through your investigative judgment
uh you have asked for that accusation to
be thrown at you because um the
accusation is is thrown at you from
people who cannot stand that
unbiblical uh understanding of the
righteousness of Christ and it is a
whole uh Doctrine invented to save Fai
from a great
disappointment that that you know the
investigative judgment no matter how
many dates they want to put on it Year
Day principle 457 BC and whatnot
it was all an invention to save
face and yet these U people who consider
themselves theologians Luther had Luther
had some chosen term for the
Scholastics that I shall not repeat you
have to get the commentary uh to uh get
the juiciness of uh Luther's flavor to
call people who taught all these false
things because again these are not new
inventions the these things to uh steal
and Rob the glory of Christ have been
around uh even before the the
Reformation I mean heresy and these
types of human righteousness elevated uh
to the Supreme uh have been around for a
long time and will be around uh for a
long time and um um God will continue to
use Earth and Broken Vessels like these
guys um to
imperfectly um say that uh uh we are
saved through faith alone by Christ
Alone through grace alone and to his
glory and we live to his glory alone so
anyhow that's I I can't believe this
stuff
really my friend thank you for spending
some time with us this evening it has
been an awesome discussion I always love
talking with you like I said it's it's I
would just describe it as like a
spiritual jacuzzi it's just ah um always
know we're going to have good good
discussion around the gospel my final
question or request from you is if you
would close us out by sharing the gospel
with our
listeners the gospel has a proper
name the gospel is not a
Doctrine the gospel is the holy person
of Jesus
Christ who voluntarily gave himself over
for our sins I would love to say my sins
but when I say our sins I'm including
myself but it's a communal
thing sin is always a communal thing so
Christ gave himself for our sins he is
my death he is my life he is my
resurrection thus he is my gospel he is
my good news in him I have entered into
my soul's Eternal
rest and I have no fear for any
judgment because I have been
justified through him alone and forever
he will stand in my place as my
righteousness and he has given me the
privilege to already be seated at his
right hand and
to uh sing with the great uh multitude
of the saved worthy worthy Worthy is the
Lamb so the gospel has uh no
asterisks no
footnote no let me clarify this because
anything that we add to the gospel will
take away his Brilliance his
brightness as my gospel my good news the
gospel cannot include
Moses it cannot include Elijah it cannot
include Moses as the law and it cannot
include Elijah as any of the prophets or
prophetesses when Christ
appears everything is gone and only he
remains and he
says my
beloved your sins have been
eternally
forgiven be of good cheer
ho to
apostate did he say
that come on man